[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
plans to clamp down on disruptive
protest as the high court hears more
than a hundred members of insulate
britain have been served in junctions to
keep them off motorways
the united states tops the list of the
world's greatest carbon emitters since
the start of the industrial revolution
while only four of the top ten have
promised substantial cuts in admissions
and the man who's picked up over a
million pieces of rubbish in a quest to
keep his local area clean
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now the home secretary has
branded protesters from the group
insulate britain as so-called eco
warriors who are trampling over our way
of life in response to repeated
demonstrations which have blocked major
roads pretty patel announced there would
be tougher penalties for anyone
disrupting a motorway and new powers for
the police to deal with them it comes as
the high court heard that more than a
hundred members of the campaigning group
have been served in junctions to stop
them demonstrating enderbrady reports
for three weeks their actions have
brought sheer frustration and anger to
london's roads
now for the first time insulate britain
have apologized but they plan to keep
going regardless
we don't want to inconvenience or even
worse cause more problems for the
british public
we don't want to do that that's not
that's not the aim of this at all we
feel we have to do it in order to avert
a greater disruption which is the
terrifying things that are coming down
the road
at the conservative party conference the
home secretary used her speech to
outline plans to crack down on
protesters who target critical
infrastructure like roads i will not
tolerate the so-called eco warriors
trampling over our way of life and
draining police resources
the high court heard that more than a
hundred activists have now been served
with injunctions
new powers for the courts could see
protesters stop from traveling in the
first place
so what are the implications of this
proposed legislation what it will send
is a chilling effect on the right to
free speech
for others that want to join protests
and and protest is is the engine of
change that that's how
change is brought about and how radical
changes brought about
uh yet this is a government that does
not want to tolerate descent
the protesters responded to pretty
patel's comments by insisting they will
ignore the injunctions and keep causing
disruption
while the government is adamant these
protesters must be stopped insulate
britain say they have no intention of
changing their strategy and they say all
through winter they will continue
blocking britain's motorways
global leaders will arrive in glasgow
from the end of this month for the cop26
climate summit it runs for two weeks and
the world will be watching how any
protests are dealt with ender brady sky
news
in today's other climate news the un
weather agency is warning that there'll
be a global water crisis without urgent
reforms a report by the organization
suggests climate change will increase
water hazards like droughts and floods
leading to water shortages it says more
funding is needed to improve water
management including better flood
warning systems in asia
the danish government has ruled that
farmers must half their greenhouse gas
emissions by 2030. the legally binding
agreement also includes a 65 reduction
for the forestry sector and a reduction
in nitrogen emissions it's part of
government plans to cut the country's
overall emissions by 70 by 2030 one of
the most ambitious targets in the world
the amount of the planet's coral reef
that's been lost to climate change is
the same size as the grand canyon
national park a study by the global
coral reef monitoring network shows that
14 of the world's coral was lost between
2009 and 2018 and scientists are warning
that more will disappear if sea
temperatures keep rising
coral bleaching overfishing and
declining water quality are all
contributing to their decline
and three scientists have been awarded
the nobel prize for physics for their
work on climate change sukuru manaba
manabe klaus hasselman and giorgio
parisi were announced as the winners at
an event in stockholm some of their
research has been used to predict the
impact of human-induced global warming
now the countries which have contributed
most to the current climate crisis have
been revealed by analysis of their
carbon dioxide emissions since the start
of the industrial revolution in 1850.
now the study from carbon brief includes
for the first time emissions from the
destruction of forests and other changes
in land use as well as the impact of
fossil fuels
and it finds that of the top 10 emitters
only four have promised substantial cuts
in emissions ahead of the climate summit
cop 26 next month so let's take a look
at the world's current top emitters and
as you can see here china
is the is has by far the largest carbon
dioxide emissions with more than 10 000
million tons of co2 in 2019 now that's
almost twice that of the us which comes
in second and they're followed by india
and russia
but this list changes when we look at
historic emissions now when we add up
all the emissions since the industrial
revolution the us replaces china as the
most prolific emitter now the u.s has
released more than 420 gigatons of co2
from fossil fuels since 1850 and is
responsible for the largest share of
historical emissions that's almost 20
percent in fact the us's carbon
emissions alone have led to 0.2 degrees
of warming so far
and the new analysis includes emissions
from land use change and forestry in
addition to fossil fuels and we can see
the top 10 emitters change again now
brazil and indonesia they overtake
canada germany india the uk and japan
and that's partially linked to forest
fires in indonesia in 1997 and
deforestation that has taken place in
brazil for cattle ranching for logging
and palm oil plantations
so let's talk a little bit more about
this analysis joining me now is dr simon
evans deputy editor of carbon carbon
brief who carried out this analysis so
welcome to you
so first of all why do you think it's
important to look at a country's
emissions in this historical context
so it's basically it's quite simple
the world
collectively has committed to hold
warming well below two degrees and
strive to limit warming to 1.5 degrees
and that
that depends on not only what we emit in
the future but what we've emitted in the
past because carbon dioxide the impact
on the climate accumulates over time
so we've already had 1.2 degrees of
warming and in order to work out how
effectively we got into this mess we
need to know who's responsible for that
for those emissions
and that's what our analysis has set out
to do
well yes and how unusual is it to study
the impact of land use and deforestation
as well as the burning of fossil fuels
and how important a role has that played
in assessing the biggest emitters
so overall since 1850 um the world you
know humans collectively have pumped out
two and a half thousand billion
tons of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere and that's directly linked to
the 1.2 degrees of warming we've seen so
far now one third of that total is is
linked to land use change and forestry
so it's really important that we include
that now it's not to say that climate
scientists have been ignoring this but
it's simply to say that when looking at
the national level
which countries individually are
responsible for those emissions that's
been much harder to do
well yes and and when assessing who has
the greatest historical responsibility
for climate change presumably that feeds
a lot into the politics the head of of
cop 26 and the idea of
how much money should be paid to
developing countries the ones least
responsible and that sense of climate
justice
yeah so i mean climate justice very much
revolves around this question of who's
responsible for the state that we're in
and who ought to do the most to to
mitigate further warming
um and you know as you say that relates
to climate um climate finance
um but also who ought to be cutting
their emissions
over the next decades and out to 2050
the most quickly in order to have uh you
know dangerous further dangerous warming
well yes i mean that that question of
pledges is interesting isn't it given
that not many of the countries in the
top ten have upped their pledges to
reduce emissions ahead of that u.n
summit
yeah so
the you know the heartbeat of the paris
agreement essentially that was was
signed in 2015 was that every five years
countries would come back and they would
say how are we doing are we on track and
the answers very clearly we're way off
track and so the idea behind paris was
they were meant to come forward with
greater ambition each country was
supposed to by 2020 submit a more
ambitious target
you know a very large number of major
emitters have so far failed to do that
and as
you said at the beginning of the
programme time is now running out before
cop 26.
dr simon evans thanks very much indeed
thank you
now one man's mission to clean up his
local area has earned him a huge
following on tick tock hundreds of
thousands of people have watched daniel
tobin's quest to clear the environment
of plastic as well as other rubbish over
10 years he's collected more than 8 000
bags of trash and he's explained to us
what motivates him to carry on
these birds are awfully raucous right
now
hey guys
i was a freshman at university
there was a stream on campus that really
bothered me because
i
and all the other students could see
that there were hundreds of plastic
bottles floating down it no one cared
enough to clean it up i felt like
the environment was unhappy there
when people litter
they don't realize that
sometimes they're actually turning
something that is reusable into
something that can't be
plastic once it gets a certain amount of
dirt inside of it
can't be recycled there is now plastic
pollution
on both the highest point on earth on
the top of mount everest
and there's plastic pollution in
marianas trench which is the deepest
point on earth
anyone who wants to help the environment
will
spend some time cleaning up plastic
pollution wherever it may be so that
they can appreciate
the natural and sacred beauty of that
place afterwards
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by economist vicki
price and the independence climate
columnist donica mccarthy and we're
going to be discussing how much would it
cost to insulate britain and the role of
nuclear power in helping us reach net
zero emissions that's coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day con access and knees
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a
moment i don't like the chinese
government it's true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches
shaban robbins sky news bangkok
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
did you know if more of us walked rolled
bikes and scooted to school we would
make a big difference to the air
pollution around our school yeah like us
britain will have a mostly dry and sunny
morning after early rain clears norfolk
ireland and northern ireland meanwhile
we'll see cloud and outbreaks of rain
spreading in it'll be a bit warmer cloud
and rain will spread to western britain
during the afternoon heavy and
persistent over western scotland while
ireland and northern ireland will see
patchy rain giving way to occasional
drizzle
clean air spreading from the atlantic
means that the air pollution index where
one means low pollution and 10 means
very high will be low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
economist and former joint head of the
uk's government economic service vicky
price and the independence climate
columnist donica mccarthy so good
evening to both of you really good to
see you both
so first of all the home secretary has
announced extra measures to deal with
protests following the disruption caused
by the insulate britain group now we've
discussed protest tactics here more than
once but what about the protesters cause
how would we insulate britain and how
much would it cost so donica to you
first of all before we drill into the
cast tell me why you think it's
important for the environment for us to
all insulate our houses
sure around 15 of the uk's carbon
emissions comes from heating and so
therefore it's crucial that we tackle
the emissions from britain's homes which
are among the worst insulated in the in
the in europe so it's essential if we
actually insulate our homes we cut
the cost of running them and the
admissions from them by over a third so
it's crucial to put this on top of the
agenda for the government
so essentially we don't need to turn the
heating up so much if we're well
insulated in our homes it helps bring
down the emissions is essentially what
you're saying is it
absolutely the the amount it would cost
to run and heat your home would be at
least a third if not more if our homes
were properly insulated
we it's not just carbon emissions though
of course it it also is the huge issue
of
excess winter deaths around 8 000
pensioners a year are dying from
actually living in cold homes across
britain
nearly five million people in britain
are living with fuel poverty having to
try and make the choice between food and
heating their homes so it's just a
no-brainer for us to be insulating our
homes across britain okay and this is
what the leader of the opposition vicky
has said about it he said we have the
least energy efficient housing in europe
so if we're going to do something about
it vicky how much would it cost
well the things that you need to do of
course when you are trying to insulate
the home particularly one which was
built some time ago is to deal with all
sorts of different parts of the house
that need
insulating so you have loft insulation
you have a cavity wall installation you
have floor insulation
you have you know drought excluders you
can do all sorts of things and of course
each of those costs and costs quite a
lot and given that we have loads of old
homes the average cost for the older
homes is considerably higher than say
building a new house or those that
perhaps have been built you know in the
last couple of decades so if you add it
all up and you look at a
north house might cost to do all these
things that i just mentioned including
of course improving the heating itself
so converting from gas boilers to other
ways of heating your home which are more
efficient could be up to 28
000 30 000 pounds it could be a bit less
for the
uh ones that were built more recently so
if you multiply that we have
29 million homes
in the uk
roughly okay so quite a lot of them need
to be insulated we're talking about
hundreds of billions and that's the real
issue where is the money going to come
from well you're shaking your head there
donald but it's a lot of money that
needs to be found how are we going to
pay for this
yeah just multiplying it by 26 million
is nonsense um 50 of uk houses already
have their walls insulated we need to
insulate the other 50
the estimate is that we need to spend 6
billion a year to 2035 that comes out as
75 billion we could actually fund that
easily by actually switching the
investment from hs2 which is just going
to cut an hour for rich people driving
by train to edinburgh to investing in
people's homes for poor people to lower
their bills and make them warm and cover
carbon emissions
and vicki the long promised heat and
buildings bill is due to be announced by
the government so we may get more
details on what their plans are but
quickly come back at donaka there he he
disagrees with your figures very briefly
you know i mean he he may be right in
terms of what has happened so far what
still is needed to be done but i mean
the the numbers are still where we said
hundreds of millions billions i'm sorry
in any case that needs to be spent but
um but the issue is
maybe maybe whatever there are loads and
loads of different calculations of what
is actually required it's still a lot of
money i don't agree that we're going to
have to think about how
that can be spent whether we should be
switching from something else and
whether in fact taxes need to be
increased but also i think there has to
be a lot of support for the individual
homeowner what we've seen is the moment
cheap options disappear the homeowner
just doesn't do the loft installations
that i need they just move out of even
bothering to do any of those uh taking
any of those measures that would save
quite a lot interesting interesting
stuff and i'm sure we'll talk a lot more
about this in the weeks ahead in the
meantime though it is all about the
money a new ambitious climate target was
set by boris johnson this week for the
uk to have a fully green electricity
grid by 2035 and that's raised once
again the subject of nuclear power let
me just take you over to the data
dashboard briefly because you can see
that at the moment at 13 of our
electricity right now our power right
now is coming from nuclear and that
number is really pretty stable now if
he's going to meet his green target does
nuclear and the stability of generation
that it gives needs to be part of the
mix donna put that question straight to
you
well the the fact is that we have to be
cutting our emissions by 2030 and if we
do even if we do decide to build size
world c that won't be built until 2040
at the earliest and every single new
nuclear power station in europe over the
last 20 years has been 10 to 15 years
late so what we should be doing is not
going down an expensive white elephant
but investing in renewables and storage
and insulation
the total nuclear uh fleet produces only
five percent of britain's um energy
needs it's a distraction from the real
concentration of energy efficiency
insulation renewables and storage
well okay okay and vicky what do you
think i mean greenpeace usa have said
nuclear energy has no place in a safe
clean sustainable future however it's
supporters would say it doesn't produce
co2 or greenhouse gases it's got a small
land footprint and it provides that
security of supply when the wind's not
blowing and the sun's not shining so
what's your take on it
i think we have been relying a bit on
nuclear and uh
the fact that uh if we leave things as
they are and we weren't building
hinckley point for example or we weren't
thinking of perhaps uh having size world
c
uh nuclear uh power station um in
prospect then we would be probably
seeing the nuclear contribution reduced
very significantly over the next few
years uh nuclear has had a useful role
to play in the sense that it provided a
bit of that base load that you need
because renewables i'm afraid uh can be
very intermittent in terms of how they
produce that energy that you require
because it may not do the windmill blow
the sun may not shine so you lose quite
a lot of that but i think there is an
alternative if you're looking ahead and
that is we may need to be thinking more
about having that baseline provided by
other means rather than nuclear for the
future because nuclear is very okay and
briefly what would that be
it would be gas
we need to probably have more gas fire
power stations yes but presumably that
would produce emissions wouldn't it so
donald what do you make of that we do we
need we can't just rely on renewables
can we
no no
that's insane um to actually go down
propose new fossil fuel power plants is
just
nonsense
what we have to be doing is actually
looking at renewables and storage
and tidal
and uh those three together if we invest
in them are cheaper than nuclear faster
than nuclear and reliable last month
five of the seven nuclear power stations
went down they're not as reliable as
people claimed them to be renewables are
far cheaper storage is far cheaper green
hydrogen is far cheaper i think you'll
both have to agree to disagree on that
one but donna vicky we are out of time
thanks both very much indeed
thank you so do stay with us that is i
mean that's everything from us with
today but stay with the channel won't
you there's plenty more are coming up in
just a moment on sky news tonight and
meanwhile tomorrow i'm going to be
joined by the host of the climate
curious podcast mariam pasha and white
house climate advisor jerome foster so
do join us tomorrow
[Music]
you